[Music]
so on tuesday i told my sister that i
thought i had a blood clot in my arm i
said i'm just gonna take a shower and
see if this resolves itself if it
happens again i'm gonna go to the er all
that week i was at a convention i had
fun i was meeting friends my arm was a
little swollen but i was kind of
ignoring it until thursday i went to a
dinner here i am at dinner with some
amazing women it was a great time went
to the dinner came home i was like
something is wrong i think i should go
to the doctors so instead of going to
the doctors i went to sleep and just
hoped that i woke up in the morning
which is a very scary thought to fall
asleep too woke up the next morning was
supposed to record a podcast uh i
decided that we had a serious issue the
veins are starting to break in my
shoulder this arm is so swollen i looked
ripped it looked like i had been to the
gym i was so shredded but that was
actually just swelling and i thought
because this is my arm that i do
lightsaber training with and i'm mostly
right-hand dominant in sports and any
type of martial arts stuff i was like
okay this is not right i need to go
somewhere now went to urgent care they
looked in my arm they said you got to go
to the er my sister races me to the
emergency room i'm there they do an
ultrasound they find a blood clot then
from there they get me a room at a
bigger hospital they take my ambulance
to the bigger hospital where they then
say yes you definitely have a blood clot
we're gonna have to do a thrombectomy
which is where they take a catheter and
shove it into your vein and pump
medicine into the clot to break it up
cool that wasn't it not too bad good no
great driving thank you thank you do you
play grand theft auto uh no no i just
watched a lot of the fast and the
furious movies i was gonna say because
you would be very good yeah
update uh have moved to a bigger
facility i don't really know what's
going on
i'm just real sad
it's real sad
i don't
don't know
so it's the morning i've i've survived
which is great
still have a slow drip of
blood thinners and now they want to go
in and
dissolve
the clot
so saturday morning rolls around they
take me down to do this procedure i
don't know anything that's happening and
the doctor wouldn't come up to see me so
they
rolled me down to the or instead so i'm
here in the operating room trying to
understand what this doctor is telling
me and the whole process and i have my
sister on the phone and then we were
also talking to our friend chris who you
may know from the youtube channel becky
and chris they do incredible like home
remodeling
they do drone stuff they have a freaking
helicopter i love their youtube videos
but chris is actually basically the
doctor that i'm talking to that's going
to do the surgery like chris could have
been the one to do the surgery and i
actually i wish he was i wish that chris
was there and he could have done it
because imagine what an incredible
youtube collab that would be
i did i just seen
blood
oh my god that's incredible
unfortunately he wasn't there but i was
in pure panic mode jenna was talking to
chris kind of behind the scenes giving
him the lowdown because i couldn't even
use my phone so it took all of my power
to like be able to find him in my phone
call him connect him with my sister and
at this point i know this doctor was
incredibly annoyed and i i apologize but
when you're being thrown into a
situation where i don't i've never been
to the hospital i've never really been
sick in my entire life so this is
traumatizing and of course the side
effects of this drug are pretty severe
that they were going to be putting in my
sister has also had patients who have
unfortunately passed away or had a
stroke because of this so it's like
having that in the back of my mind as
i'm sitting there in this stark
cold operating room with people around
me and no one
that i knew or anything i don't know it
was just such a surreal experience so i
call chris i'm like crying i have my own
personal diagnostics and interventional
radiologists on the line and my
pharmacist so please hold we have some
things to discuss we do that we go in
they put the catheter and they decide
that they're going to do this drug
called tpa to dissolve it i didn't know
what that was i was freaking out crying
i was in the bathroom this is actually a
shot of me crying in the bathroom i was
like this might be the last clip that is
ever on my phone that's really pathetic
and sad but i go back in we decided
we're going to do it we're going to do a
low dose do that for 24 hours and come
back i mean we maybe should have done
the full dose but there's a chance that
i would have had to have done
the full thing twice so also this whole
time i refused to give up my phone like
i was like absolutely not and i'm just
like trying to like film random pieces
and when they're they were putting me to
sleep i was just like saying weird stuff
doing weird stuff
yeah
i talk about iphones a lot
so if you've ever been on youtube and
saw a
crazy girl talking about an iphone
it's huge
it's very well do it has been turned the
phone off
[Music]
and i know i haven't actually really
even made a youtube video about this but
i've been very
um into kind of like exploring the nft
and the web 3 space and i've learned so
much and the reason that i haven't even
made a video about it yet is because i'm
kind of trying to learn the pros the
cons and kind of find out what people
hate about it what people love about it
and kind of find this middle ground and
be able to explain it properly to you
that has been on my mind for the past
four months of just doing research and
uh
so the first thing that i do when i wake
up out of my anesthesia coma because
they start asking everybody like hey you
guys got any nfts who
who has fts here
i'm so tired
because
i think i have to put the cloud on if
you're a woman i'm sorry that's where
the people go that's where they walk
that's where they're wrong where they
stay out there in the sun for my main
project i'm going to do on salona
because it's environmentally friendly
just saying crazy nonsense i may have
said swear word at the end but uh
forgive me i was on drugs
i'm reporting to the camera that i've
survived everyone has been so nice i've
told me
come back the next day didn't work i
gotta do it again
yeah but that's okay
because
well it's not i tried to offer my doctor
a hundred dollars because i knew i had a
hundred dollars
you actually have 140. oh my god tell it
yeah that's like four coffees
i think he will take it i'll think he'll
take it this has been 13 hours of your
second treatment i was so defeated first
treatment didn't work well it got
partial it got partial so now we upped
the dosage so i have to be on this for
another 24 hours and at this point i
can't move my arms at all like my sister
is feeding me she's brushing my teeth
she's brushing my hair needing
assistance to go to the bathroom which
was absolutely not a good time at all so
you survived one night in the icu second
night being an er
icu how do you feel well pretty terrible
but the one thing that i told jenna to
bring for me was some dry shampoo and as
you said it was already in my bag
let's get beautiful we're going to have
spa day jenna just brushed my teeth
again so
now it's hair time
oh geez my mom
this one smells good yeah i'm sorry i
mean it's great it's lovely it's not
that nice
okay let's see the swollen digits
yeah it's a pretty small one
it's way less swollen so basically now
i'm gonna go in for a procedure to make
sure that this catheter
actually broke up the blood clot
and then
i think they take it out and then
they're gonna do some little like x-ray
thing
it's really hard to say oh knock knocks
so my friend ro you guys all know row
and mike bro texted my sister and was
like i know you said do visitors but i'm
coming anyway we were supposed to go to
hawaii this weekend so i was supposed to
be flying out one thing that you can't
do with a blood clot is get on a plane
or at least you should the doctor did
tell me i could but i think he was just
like i'm sick of your rambling and i'm
just going to tell you what you want to
hear and ro has brought hawaii to me
oh my god i'm not crying i went through
checking girl
like this i was like
i even took little lessons in college up
over here
you guys can take this show on the road
this is impressive
oh
i'll go get that fries the best crying
because i knew i couldn't go to hawaii
but also laughing because like she's in
my
in the icu room where you're not even
supposed to like bring gifts or like you
know
have flowers or like anything but i
i didn't have any of that i had a
full-on
hula show
with candy and treats and a dancer which
was rosanna so it was incredible so
thank you mike and ro for thinking of me
and coming to visit me in my darkest
hour which i think that was that day was
pretty tough so that definitely lifted
my spirits
let's hope we have empty clot yay no
clothes no clock gang here we go
three two one so here we are third
time's a charm we go back in and
this
thankfully worked there she is
so i can't i couldn't cancel your flight
there yet you still have a flight there
but the rest of it
the rest of it
i think you're gonna stay here with me
we'll have fun here
i feel like i'm making this all seem
very wow yeah this isn't a big deal no a
blood clot is a very serious issue like
you could die the blood clot could break
off into your heart to your lungs to
your head you could have a stroke it's
not something to be taken lightly and
with that being said that evening after
they said that the clot was gone it was
dissolved i started having chest pains
shortness of breath i started getting a
little worried and something did not
feel right i felt something like
traveling so now i'm in sort of like i
guess like the cardiac ward uh
so we're here
i've been here all day this is the arm a
lot of stuff has happened to this little
arm
but it's
you're doing your job i'm about to get a
ct scan having a little bit of chest
pain and like if you're here for a blood
clot and you have some chest pain like
that's when you should probably go get
it checked out so i'm gonna go do that
other than that my morale is pretty high
um
i can't wait to change the sports bra
and
it's been on me for a while we're gonna
have to cut it off because i'm all
hooked up
spirits are moderate do i say that
they're high they're not very high
really so i hate needles i absolutely
hate them so every time somebody comes
in to take my blood i get a little
panicky so basically this entire
i guess hospital trip has been
one big
breathing exercise
breathe through it the power of breath
is actually quite impressive it's
honestly the only way i've survived this
is just like
staying calm i hate needles hate
hospitals i'm never sick so this whole
experience has
not been not been fun but
it's okay
the blood has been drawn the scary thing
though is because i'm on blood thinners
it's like i have to be super careful
about falling so that night at 1 30 a.m
they'd end up taking me down for a ct
scan late night fun ct scan they inject
dye into
your vein to kind of see the the flow
and it all kind of happens sort of very
quickly so like i'm in there with like
my arms up and it's like this big sort
of
machine that they just like stick you in
at this point i hadn't raised my arms up
in like four days so
doing that was so painful when i was
inside of the machine i could feel when
they shot the die out that some of it
like leaked out like i could feel it
leaking out but the machine tells you to
stop breathing and stop moving and so i
was like yelling i'm like i think it's
legging out but then the machine goes
stop breathing i was like
i stopped so i was like okay i don't
want to do this again so i need to just
like we need to see if we can get this i
hope that this was for the best the ct's
dye stuff felt so freaking weird the
guy's like you're probably gonna feel
like really warm and like a little like
metallic-y taste in your mouth and then
you might feel like you're gonna pee
yourself
i'm like okay
okay
felt all of those things did not enjoy
he said the scan was good enough they
got enough dye in thankfully like i'm of
a smaller stature person cool well i go
to sleep that night wake up in the
morning and then everyone's like okay so
i think we're gonna be like sending you
home today you know everything kind of
came back looking looking good i was
like okay all right and then later
there's like a change of shifts i spoke
to another doctor and he's like so you
had a pe um there's a blood clot in your
right
something over here and then my lung i
don't know what's in my chart whatever
it doesn't matter either way it's there
oh cool like that's what we've been
trying to avoid this whole time right
he's like yeah
the girl's been unhooked from the
heparin which means i now have to take
pill form but hey
i had a pulmonary embolism which means a
piece of the blood clot
broke off and went to my lungs
that's cool but they're still letting me
leave tiny one day tiny tiny so
basically the same treatment that they
would be doing here it would just be
blood thinner so they're like
did a ct scan
everything looks
well not good but like good enough that
we think you can go home
and take your own drugs yourself
so that's where we are currently at
my breathing okay i don't even know
your vitals are all good you're walking
around and a lot of times when people do
come in with this really the only
treatment that we have for them is we
send them with blood thinners so i was
already on super high dose of blood
thinners and then i had a little
breakfast and a little lunch
waiting around waiting to go home and i
finally got cleared for it yeah then i
was i was discharged they're like peace
all right here we go
foot rest oh i have a foot lost
premium
premium treatment
we're out this whole process was so
shocking and traumatizing and scary
because this is a very serious thing
like it's not something to take lightly
so if you ever kind of have that weird
feeling of numbness swelling in any of
your extremities like blood clots are
absolutely no joke
you should seek medical attention
immediately because it can be very
detrimental and even if you are young
like that doesn't matter like being
young and healthy is is trivial because
clearly if i'm so young and so healthy
why did i have something like this like
anything can happen to anyone at any
time and i think just the fact that that
even in my mind
on tuesday when i was like
i'm just gonna kind of let it go and see
what happens like i should have went on
tuesday 100 should have went i may seem
like i'm in pretty good health and great
condition right now but the last five
days at the hospital was absolutely
traumatizing i couldn't use my arms i
could basically do nothing my arm was so
freaking swollen when i went in there
that the doctor was actually like
shocked she's like what happened to you
and i go well that's why i'm here tell
me what's wrong so one of the diagnosis
that they think it's a possibility is
there is compression of my rib on this
vein so i might have to get a rib
removed but they said i keep the rib
bonus points probably turn into a nice
necklace
fashion there's also some other things
they can do just to remove kind of like
that compression so there's a lot of
answers that need to be answered so i'm
kind of in that process right now but
all things considered i can like i'm
good right now like i'm
i feel pretty good i'm now in blood
thinners but with blood thinners also
comes a lot of risks of uh if i like hit
my head or even just like simple
scratches or small wounds because the
blood thinner like i could potentially
bleed out very very scary and i'm just
very grateful to still be here this is
just a reminder that if you ever feel
like something is wrong and not right
with your body like don't hesitate to go
seek medical help because if i wouldn't
have there are so many outcomes where
this could have been way more tragic and
i'm grateful that we found it early had
an incredible medical team and a huge
thank you to everyone that was there to
support me through this and to my sister
who had to feed me and brush my hair and
basically was my caretaker for the past
five days oh my god jenna thank you
you're a hero you're the best
um yeah so
i'll uh
see you guys in the next video
peace
am i supposed to go to hawaii this
weekend
hey
do you do you think i could fly to
hawaii this weekend
probably not huh
hey moxie
[Music]